ich habe fünf Freunde angerufen die mir
alle eine Zahl von 1 bis 9 genannt haben
aus der dann eine Postleitzahl entstand
und genau dort bin ich hingefahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vier drei okay also ab ins Auto und für
viereinhalb Stunden auf die Autobahn die
Stadt in der ich gelandet bin und zu der
die Postleitzahl passte nennt sich
Rothenburg ob der Tauber sie befindet
sich in Bayern und ich muss sagen ich
habe noch nie vorher davon gehört umso
überrascht da war ich dann aber doch als
ich in die Altstadt gegangen bin alles
sieht aus wie im Mittelalter oder wie
bei Game of Thrones viele schöne Ecken
eine Burgmauer und richtig tolle
Restaurants leider ist schon um 22 Uhr
alles dicht und es wird gar nichts mehr
am nächsten Tag habe ich dann noch einen
Schneeball gegessen mich ein bisschen
weiter umgeschaut und bin schon wieder
nach Hause gefahren aber ich war mal in
Rothenburg ob der Tauber